oh hello
[Music]
hello
what's goody
hello everyone
welcome bizack it is our weekly feedback
hour
I don't want them to hear me yelling
like an idiot in my office
[Music]
to think that it's all good everything's
okay here
so welcome everyone welcome as we're
coming in here Yoshi will be joining me
shortly
he was dropping his daughter off
they have like a family and stuff hmm
this is gonna be a good one today I'm
super jazzed about it
this is
of course our weekly joke feedback hour
my friends are coming on in I see Ron
jamming in the comments who else we got
in here who else we got watching
or who are you who's out there
who's out there
who's out there hmm
hope you're all having a good Tuesday
let me know where you are watching from
as we come in here
this is our weekly joke feedback hour my
friends hello Victoria
great to see you Victoria
[Music]
great to see you great to see you
great to see you great great to see you
Ron Jamin
ouch yeah
good to see you my friend
Gadsden Alabama good to see you Gene
doggy good to see you fam Victoria all
the way from NYC where it is cold
foreign good to see you
Ron jamming out in Utah yeah we rolling
deep today
Ron said I'm thinking of starting a kill
Tony type podcast here at the local
events center
good luck
go for it
yeah yeah the sky is the limit my
friends you can do anything you put your
mind to
the more you know and then we have like
a more you know thing fly across the
more you know
oh we rolling deep we got Trevor out
here in Lafayette Louisiana good to see
you Trevor Dennis Tooley
how are things in the Glorious state of
Georgia they're very glorious here my
in-laws are here so
um we're about to go on a family
vacation
um for like 10 days
so um I won't be able to do this next
week and I won't be able to do write 10
Club the next two weeks
[Music]
um
but um everything is glorious here it's
a very pretty day it's been a bit of an
up and down day as some are but that's
all part of it my friends
Victoria's about ready to not eat or
drink for 25 hours oh my heavens
good luck with that I hope it's nothing
serious
sashka good to see you sashka she said
hey guys hey
of course Ron would love to do this show
of course
and what we doing today my friends is uh
you know a little joke feedback so if
you have a joke you'd like some feedback
on go ahead and post it in there
go ahead and post your jokes here in the
live stream we'll give you some feedback
on them
Yoshi will be joining us shortly my
co-host
I am Kapoor she says
oh and Yoshi is here one second oh
Christopher said I saw you
at JP Comedy Club here in Arizona you
were great I'm a new subscriber and
aspiring comedian let's go
[Music]
what's good fam good good to see you in
here
awesome great to see you hanging out
with us here Christopher what's goody
Jordan leaving in the building idiot on
the comedy circuit good to see you oh
gosh like I missed Yoshi
Corey good to see you Corey Corey posted
a joke as well
there he is
yeah we rolling deep today fam we
rolling deep today
um
and Ladies and Gentlemen let's let's
welcome to the show oh my gosh it's
Yoshi so everyone
[Laughter]
got the haircut I had
you have it you have hair to cut
yeah man I can't just be stubbly out
here oh man you got that line tight a
little high and tight
I'm not LeBron James
hilarious
we appreciate you
um sneaking us into your family schedule
Yoshi
yeah bro
yeah yeah we were just uh welcoming
everyone we had a Christopher Williams
who saw me when I was out in Arizona
and uh always good always good to see
new peeps in here I think this is his
first time popping in here I don't know
if anyone else's first time but welcome
welcome
and look at Dennis Tooley said Yoshi did
great at the world series of Comedy
let's go
really good advice
this is awesome
I appreciate it big time
yeah applause applause applause oh
Justin W first time what's up what is
goody goody what's goody fam
we rolling deep so
uh we're gonna be doing some joke
feedback today and Yoshi you and I
normally will like say a joke each for
feedback but
I saw a really good question in our
Facebook group that I think may be worth
talking about and let it but we can also
if you have a joke you're itching to do
we can also do that but I thought this
was a really interesting question
um
I thought would be worth
I thought would be worth answering
because it did get a lot of Engagement
in our Facebook group and for the peeps
if this is your first time
um hanging out with us here and you're
watching on
um YouTube we do have a Facebook group
where we do a daily joke running contest
and people can ask questions and things
like that
um that I will link I'm live streaming
this into our Facebook group as well but
I will link it in our YouTube live chat
wants to go join
join us over there because there's a
there's almost 5 000 comics from around
the world in there writing jokes giving
each other feedback and such
um
5K baby yeah we rolling so um
as I go get that link how are you doing
how are you doing overall Yoshi how's
I'm doing good man uh this week has been
a little different mostly because my
wife is out of town so I've been like in
charge of all kid duty
being a parent who
a word is it worth it
uh it's it's worth it for sure like the
the hugs and the adorableness of your
Offspring is great
um but it's a lot of work
that's a lot of the whole time there's
no clocking out there there's no
clocking out
uh no clocking out like as soon as like
I had a good weekend so like I've had it
maybe for like I say I've had them as if
I'm babysitting yeah because that's what
that happens
for like a week like without uh the
wifey at the house that we had a good
week and a good weekend and then Monday
hits and then my son's sick so yes
and then I had to deal with that and
then like still got the like daily
schedules like everyone's got like four
things they gotta go to I got gymnastics
I got soccer
it's like just on top of other stuff and
then you're like yo I forgot to pee
today that's hilarious dude is that a
bit that's hilarious
that is so funny dude
I mean I was just like just going like
and you're like oh okay I guess this is
just what it is a very newfound respect
for my wife for sure it's like the thing
is we've like she's left me with the
kids for like a weekend but this will be
the first time in like 20 years where
it's been
a week
and we're both not there yeah
not 20 years but like you know we've had
kids for 12 years yeah yeah yeah yeah
Dana fan
well thanks for doing in spite of all
that you're you're parenting Yoshi hot
breath is gonna take care of yours
because this is I've been looking
forward to it and I need a release my my
yeah my my in-laws just got into town
because we're about we're about to go
out of town tomorrow morning and I was
like we got to do this feedback hour
because for the next 11 days I'm gonna
be going
I won't have any stage time I'm gonna be
like
no I mean it's going to be great it's
going to be great for sure we're gonna
have a blast but it is like I gotta get
my sillies out oh yeah I when I got uh
I'm I'm in the basement when I got here
I locked the doors I was like Hey nobody
Disturbed Daddy for that
then you're gonna be like do I smell
smoke
they got into my stash
[Laughter]
see that's a misdirect children we
thought the house was on fire but they
were really just blowing Daddy's gag
just just just in case they find it so
that loud pack the loud pack anyway
some people call it medication that's
true that is true
where the side effect is coughing until
you want to die so it's got to be good
for you right
I always love that part like the good
stuff makes you cough like you're sick I
was like is that how medicine works I
don't know bro
so
I mean I know it can be medicinal but
most of it's just like potheads like but
whatever
I mean I ain't Throwing Shade but uh I
think it's just funny
yeah oh for sure
so send all of your drugs to P.O box
1066 Tucker Georgia 30085
[Laughter]
if they can get to the U.S Postal
Service then it was worth it yeah yeah
that is my XPO box it's been a good week
I feel like I ranted about my week but
it's been good honestly it's been fun
it's been good how's your how's your
week been dude oh it's been good yeah
it's been good just trying to get ahead
of the curve before um going out of town
for 11 days
yeah we're just so in it it's like a
vacation it's like what but no I'm like
I want to keep working
um but we should have balance I think
that's the healthy thing to do
for sure yes absolutely balance is so
important you need it in all aspects of
your life yes yes yeah yeah all is well
we've got jokes being posted here
so
um
oh Ron said oh you'll camp in your
vehicle in the parking lot oh he said
when we come out there we'll
oh he's making a joke oh Ron he said
it's 4 20 somewhere
oh dude he said buttered ass weed if we
if
like if we copyright that I think people
would will take it for sure
you think so oh dude
buttered ass weed is just a great
sounding name
that's one of the side effects that's
leaky
never mind
[Laughter]
oh Dennis said he's coming to Georgia
for two weeks oh interesting very nice
speaking of Georgia Dan Conroy
first time oh Dan Dan did um a spot on
our show we doing Tucker oh nice he uh
he pulled up just he was like oh hey I
love the podcast and all that and then I
gave him five minutes and he did really
well
awesome I love that I could have gone
either way
but the fact that you mentioned his name
thanks for hanging out Dan we give joke
feedback here oh and Justin W first time
good to see you fam
so uh yeah as y'all post your jokes here
um
do uh Ben Webb from Omaha what's goody
fam so yes post your jokes in the live
chat and we'll give you some feedback I
I just we don't have to spend too much
time on this but I thought it was just a
relevant question in our Facebook group
that really got some good engagement so
basically the question was from
John James hunsmeyer
who said what do you do when you feel
you don't have the it Factor as a
stand-up comic I've been doing writing
and I feel lost I am not getting the
consistent laughs I want at shows and
sometimes it all seems pointless
oh the age-old question
worth it um
apply asking how long he'd been doing
comedy because I felt like that could
really
determine the kind of feedback I gave
him but um he didn't reply yet on how
long you've been doing comedy but I
think this is a general question it's a
lot of newer Comics typically that are
um tuned into the show so um how do you
kind of deal with this
um like
you know I I would say just to know that
this is normal first thing like this is
a cool thing to like be like why what in
the hell nothing's working none of my
jokes are landing is this worth worth it
like this is a very normal thing that I
think a lot I mean I know a lot of
comedians that go through this regularly
from industry veterans to people who
started like you know a couple months
ago so this is a very normal thing I
would say the thing that keeps me going
is
uh just to kind of always go back to
like my passion of wanting to make
people laugh and I never forget that
even on days when it feels like it sucks
or when a bomb has taken place on stage
you're just like yo
that was not fun
um but for every bomb I always look
forward to like the next time that I'm
gonna kill so I always say it kind of
just comes back to
why are you doing this right like just
that sort of core like reason why I love
making people laugh I think it is like I
think we are like uh as comedians I
think we are saviors to the world
because we are doing the world a Justice
by helping people say words that are in
their mind but we do it better on a
stage and so for that reason I feel like
it is almost purpose-built that I help
this world get more laughter into it
however I do that I don't know but it
keeps me going like that little inch of
like just Humanity of helping out the
world
get more laughter
that's where I get it
um and that's where I kind of go to but
when it comes to like writing or like
writer's block or anything like that man
you can write about anything I think
sometimes you just gotta like when it's
not working try something different
that's how I look at it because I can
write about anything just freestyle
writing and I think a lot of times write
about that frustration write about like
feeling that you have of just like
why things aren't working man I have
found many of great bits and many of
great comedy when I'm in a depressive
anxious nervous and not in the greatest
of mood state
mainly because like that's very normal
and very human so that that's what I say
is where I find inspiration when it
doesn't feel like it's going well
yeah definitely I definitely think it is
a two-parter of like yeah the writing
and Performing side but then also just
like the mental side of it and I know um
like Ron Jamin just said keep writing
and getting on stage and tape your shows
and listen back and um a lot of people
in the Facebook group are saying similar
things and I think it does it really
does come down to remembering why you do
it to begin with you know I mean because
and to remember you're not alone I think
this feeling is totally normal and it's
very common and
professionals 20 years and go through
this I mean goodness there's so many
stories I think there's a story of uh I
think Dane Cook was about to quit and
then he popped off like the next day
maybe I think similar with like Joe Coy
like there's so many examples of people
who like
from the outside looking in you're like
oh man they have it all figured out
everything's perfect but
everyone goes through this feeling I've
gone through this feeling gosh during
the pandemic I was like am I even a
comedian anymore am I gonna have to go
back to Enterprise Rent-A-Car like what
am I doing like like
so just understanding that that aspect
is completely normal and common and it
can help to get out of it like you said
remembering what to do and then also
doing like John did of like posting in
the Facebook group connecting with other
like-minded comedians getting feedback
and support we need that Community
aspect in our lives so that really makes
a big difference
oh who who posted this someone said Tom
Segura
oh Victoria said I know a guy who
attempted suicide then got asked to open
for Tom Segura
oh is that how you get to open for
Thompson girl
no
is that all it takes oh
I'm calling now wait a minute yeah
Dennis Cooley said it's not about
getting laughs it's about giving the
audience a chance to laugh Jerry curl
said in the beginning don't compare
yourself to the big names look at people
who are at your experience level but
don't obsess on comparisons work with
people who support you
for sure yeah yeah yeah definitely not
comparing
um yeah definitely not comparing
yourself to each other
um and just yeah being grateful
remembering why you started to begin
with
yeah no you're not alone
comedy happens at the speed that it's
meant to happen I know people that are
two years in to Comedy and have already
gotten JFL and I'm not comparing myself
to them that's great and I wish them
like the best of luck but I'm I'm good
where I am with my comedy I put in the
exact amount of work that I want to with
the way that I'm doing comedy today do I
want more of course but am I working at
it absolutely right like I'm still
writing I'm still doing the things that
you're supposed to do as a comedian but
also just doing it for me more than
anything else so yeah get that
comparison thing like out of your head
no everyone's different everyone makes
it in a different way everyone's style
is different everyone has stylistic
reasons why they you know pick one thing
over the other none of that matters man
just get on stage make people laugh and
um yeah just always go back to that why
I think is a big thing for me and a lot
of times it's easy to
focus on what isn't working instead of
what is working so even in Just John's
like post here
he's talking about I'm not getting
consistent laughs at shows hey the
positive is you're getting up at shows
like it's
right yeah exactly at least you're on a
stage there's people that are like I'm
not getting any laughs when I say it in
my own head yeah that's a problem
exactly
yeah yeah if you're doing it right and I
think that's that's such a good point I
think Community is a huge thing right
you got to surround yourself with people
that want to see you win you got to
surround yourself with people that are
willing to help you out and you got to
surround yourself with people that you
want to be as well right it's important
to ask these kind of questions two
fellow comedians hey I'm stuck I feel
like nothing's working what can I do to
get out of it I think it's so important
I mean that's that's part of the reason
for hot bread and I think that kind of
community especially if it's positive
and it gives you like the amount of
energy that you're putting back into it
and that that can go a very long way
for sure yep so I hope I hope that helps
um peeps out there John and um everyone
else watching who sees us I hope that
helps you just know you're not alone and
this is a this is a marathon not a
Sprint so just keep your eyes on your
own paper and just focus on what you can
control which is how much you're writing
and how much you're performing and how
proactive you are and engaging with the
comedy community like John did with this
post and I think a quick note on writing
is
um lowering the bar I think especially
now there's so much comedy content and
education and everyone feels like oh I
heard I took this one class I heard this
one podcast now I figured it out I mean
it's like it's very incremental and half
the time I'm writing it's journaling
like it the vast majority of the time
when I'm like sitting down and writing
it's literally like journaling it may
just be brainstorming like I'm not
coming up with comedy magic the majority
of the time that I am writing like it's
just the practice and exercise of
writing that's that's what builds up but
it yeah no one is sitting down and just
creating comedy gold every time it's I'm
a big fan of that's why the right 10
Club started because it was like an
incremental way to just write a little
bit whether it's good or bad you wrote
and you'd feel better afterwards so
lower the bar on your writing because
most of it's going to just be the
practice of writing and there isn't
going to be like some joke that comes
out that day but in a week all that
accumulation of writing may add up to
then oh I had a big breakthrough
facts oh I'm getting roasted as we're
doing this about Michael Sarah I thought
I thought we were trying to be nice here
but I guess we got Michael Sarah jokes
coming back in now okay
there we go see the comedy community
it's very supportive yes
but uh I hope I hope that helps that
just seemed like such a relevant topic
that I think so many Comics go through
at literally every level from like new
open Micah to like professional that you
see on TV everybody goes through this
yeah very very true gosh we're we are so
good at this
yeah we are
No Cap fam go chat yeah yeah
um
Joel is the Great Value Michael Sarah
face ass that's what Dad said
yeah great value Michael Sarah is also
the biggest like great value is the
biggest one of the biggest brands in the
world so yeah I think I'll take it I can
be the Kirklands of Comedy I'll take
that yeah yeah yeah I took a photo as
Michael Sarah one time at a show
oh my gosh are you Michael Sarah can I
get your picture and I was like sure
it was dope
whatever it takes exactly
let's get into there let's get into
y'all's jokes see you later Ron Jammin
Ron had to peace out good to see you
there buddy I think he was still at work
um which is very funny
but
let's get into it today so Rick asked
what's the word today so we do the word
of the day writing on Wednesday mornings
this is joke feedback where you post a
joke you've written before and then we
will give you feedback on it so do post
an existing joke you'd like to get
feedback on
and um we are gonna start from the
beginning
looks like we have Bobby Sutton here
good to see you Bobby hello
oh where'd that go oh no
oh no
what is that
I don't know what is happening
hold on hold on his eyes or something
yeah I I hit a I tried to hit a sound
effect oh my gosh
there I was trying to hit Bobby's sound
effect and ended up throwing this I
think I needed to do all right one
second everyone
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
no this is gonna be great watch this
everyone it'd be great
this is gonna be great
there we go and then we bring it behind
the overlay
nice there we go okay we're back
we're back
foreign
all right
so
let's get into it so the first joke
that I am seeing here is from looks like
Corey Corey Kidwell and I believe this
is the guy that started the whole
Michael Sarah roasting session
um so we may skip his
no we'll get them in here come on in
Corey thank you for using your Tinder
profile picture to post your joke
um
here we go looks like Jeffrey Dahmer's
before photo so
[Laughter]
right before he saw negro he wanted to
eat
oh yeah I cannot believe that show is
popping off like it is someone dude
I posted I posted a a quick clip of me
like like I have like I do all these
these like videos like these video like
breakdowns of Comedians and there's
outtakes and I posted an outtake today
where I like yelled because I messed up
and then Chris James in the comments
goes that went from Disney to Dahmer
real quick foreign
that's so good that's a good line it was
so good
[Laughter]
but let's get to Corey's joke we're
rolling deep man we we over 30 people in
here right now so thank you all so much
we out here share this YouTube link if
y'all are
uh on YouTube share it on your Twitter
or whatnot let more peeps in here uh
Corey okay here we go
everyone Focus
or truth social wherever you get your
uh slipping slides are the best all you
need is a decent Hill a water source and
your creepy Uncle to stop staring at
your wife's bikini
I don't hate it
uh in terms of a power of Threes
um and just just so y'all uh no Yoshi's
gonna be parenting during this so you
guys are gonna have to give him a chance
to
go in and out on feedback because he is
raising a family right now while doing
this for y'all for free by the way
um but I like the power of Threes here I
think it's a funny misdirect I think it
could just be
the premises slip and slides are the
best I think it could be more connected
to something around being creepy or slip
and slides bring families together or it
could be something more like that in the
setup of it you know yeah I think slip
and slides bring my brings my family
together would be a better setup and
then you just go into it right
and it makes it personal rather than
making it sound like you're just talking
about slip and slides uh the creepy
Uncle to stop staring at your wife's
bikini I felt like
I got the visual but I feel like there
could be more
to it
because it just feels like very long to
get that visual in
yeah and instead of your uh make it my
yeah yeah very true like because you
also have a dedicated piece of Hill
water source
and then I was thinking maybe what if
it's just your creepy Uncle uh
if that would just be good
instead of staring at your wife's bikini
yeah
oh Jordan leaving said
um all you need is a hill water source
and health insurance yeah
but if we're just doing strictly a joke
like the joke structure is there I mean
there's clearly a power of threes and
the third one is absurd and it's like a
misdirect so on that end yeah there is
um there is a misstrike there for if
we're looking at strictly joke
um
yeah but personalize it bring that
premise of personalizing it back to the
top of it yeah um make it your uncle
versus uh I mean he does make it your
uncle but like make it my uncle my uncle
yeah and my uncle to stop staring at my
wife's bikini
beans
all right
good good first one there well I mean I
won't say good I don't know if it's
gonna end up on the Hall of Fame
anywhere but it does get the juices
flowing
Michael Sarah
um
why are you looking for the next joke
somebody asked if
I ever get bothered if people ever ask
me to tell a joke
um I don't get bothered by it I I think
over the years I I have like go-to jokes
depending on the audience depending on
who I'm talking to or who's asking
because usually if they're asked if
they're asking the question tell me a
joke they've already been it's already
been established that I'm a comedian and
I'm actually completely okay just
telling them like a quick one-liner just
to get them like oh okay you are funny
kind of thing or and I also have baited
people be like ah I can't really give
you all of this but I've got a show
coming up on Saturday oh yeah that's
good yeah yeah so yeah I mean I would
say use it as an opportunity rather than
thinking of it as like a negative like
when someone says like I almost think of
it as if someone asks you to tell a joke
in that moment they're really just
trying to justify whether you are what
you said you are like a comedian but
also it's obviously not the environment
you don't have the stage you don't have
a microphone you don't have all those
other things I think it's more they just
want to see your personality more than
anything that's the root of that
question yeah it's not really
necessarily that you need to tell a joke
good good question there
um all right
um
Jordan lieben
uh who chose the dates for Hispanic
Heritage Month September 15th to October
15th it shows up 15 days late that
actually jumps the Border from one month
to the next
oh
I see what you did there
um
I think you don't have to phrase this as
a question and you just go into Hispanic
heritage as much as from September 15th
to October 15th
it shows up 15 days late then actually
judge the border from one month to the
other almost synthesize it rather than
framing it as a question
yeah
and it could be making it a positive so
instead of like who chose this date it's
like I love whoever chose the date for
Hispanic Heritage Month or the dates for
Hispanic Hispanic Heritage Month are
perfect
uh it shows up 15 days late then
actually jumps the border from one but
to the next like knowing it's
yeah yes and I think that positiveness
also uh displays your emotion about it
and that's kind of what's missing here
it's like these are just facts right but
we have no idea what you feel about it
so
um it comes off as if though it's like
you're just curious about it and being
ambivalent doesn't really necessarily
work in comedy you like it you hate it
you're curious about it you don't want
to do it like choose something but pick
some kind of emotion yes and I think you
choose positivity it works better
because then people are on board with it
more and an overall joke writing rule
like it's always better to tell instead
of ask like asking a question and then
leaves it open for the audience to then
yell out or then it leaves the audience
thinking about oh I wonder what the
answer to that question is and now
they're thinking instead of like
listening to you it's this isn't 100
rules sometimes people do questions and
it's hilarious but overall
A good rule of thumb is whenever you can
to tell instead of ask
yeah limit limit questions when possible
for sure
oh it's my guy that saw me in Arizona at
JP's all right my parents have always
told me growing up that marijuana is the
gateway drug which I never understood
when I'd sneak back home I could never
figure out how to open the gate
that's pretty good that's pretty soft
silly yeah yeah yeah
um I think probably the only thing I
would say is just less words uh to get
there it's just very long-winded just
like when I'd come home I couldn't
figure out how to open the gate like
just less words but the premise of it is
solid
yeah when I'd sneak back home I could
never figure out how to open the gate
or it could be
um
my parents always told me growing up
that marijuana is the gateway drug which
I never understood
I mean just even when I'd sneak back
home I couldn't open the gate
yeah
like just it's just so many beats to get
to the punch and then I think there's
like an element of what other tags can
you add to it
um because I think it's very funny I
just like the phrasing of like gateway
drug that's very funny yeah I agree and
maybe it maybe it tightens up to like I
never understood why my parents told me
marijuana was a gateway drug whenever I
sneak back home I could I can never
figure out how to open the gate or like
just all these little adjustments really
make a big difference in how a joke will
hit or not
but I like it overall yeah
tighten it up yeah yeah
nicely done there Christopher well done
I like that yeah yeah
uh JT
all right I was arguing with my friend
about whose watch was more correct so I
told him at the end of the day it's 12
o'clock
whose watch was more correct
I don't know if I get it
I don't get it is it like a high noon
like play or something like that like is
it supposed are we supposed to fight at
12 o'clock
that's the only thing I can think of is
like something about High Noon
because it's about arguing with my
friend
at 12 o'clock he's and then his reply he
goes that
so I don't know which part
I think it's the high noon Park
I think so
okay
yeah
I I don't yeah I don't that I guess that
needs to be more clear in the setup then
somebody says it's a Tony hinch clip
joke that never made it to a set
[Laughter]
oh he rewrote it oh did he rewrite it oh
no oh did I
yeah
I didn't read all that part okay
my friend at midnight about whose watch
was more correct he said mine was five
seconds ahead I said his was five
seconds behind so I told him at the end
of the day it's 12 o'clock
yeah I still don't get it even if it's
longer
yeah sometimes something's missing for
me on this one I'm not really sure and
this is the original one we read
because the end of the day is a pun I
guess we maybe we just don't know um
are we just dumb that might be it I mean
or the joke
I mean let's be fair now it could be
either way here
I was trying to give them the benefit
you you really were I'm glad you're a
good cop today I appreciate that
midnight and then JT said bad joke
forget it oh it's basically a pun okay
so people are getting it
sorry sorry JT I do see people saying oh
at the end of the day it's 12 o'clock
so
here's the thing about a joke like this
right
this is probably one of those jokes that
I think may work better like as a tweet
yeah yeah
won't get the reference because of all
the things that you're saying about it
or just might be better like on a
Snapple bottle or something
yeah or you know at the end of the day
it's midnight maybe that would help a
little bit
when it comes down to it at the end of
the day it'll be midnight or
I
yeah I think there's more I think JT can
do better I'd like to challenge him to
yeah at the end of the day write a
different joke
but that being said
people get that it was a pun I I just
didn't but there are people in the
comments who did get that it was a pun
so
yeah like Yoshi said as a tweet perhaps
but I think on stage it's a little it's
a little bit of a leap
for people to get there
yeah but uh we do appreciate you posting
JT and we do hope that feedback helps
um
but something something about jokes like
this as well is something we talk about
on here like a lot is like what are
jokes you can write that only you can
tell so this is kind of a joke that like
anyone could really like do and it
probably gets about the same response or
like you know you know or any response
but
um positive response so it's it's like
tapping into what about your life and
your experiences JT that you can start
to write about and that's when you
really start to find your comedic voices
when you tap into those personal
experiences and stories
um but for the sake of doing a pun it
seems like people
people in the chat got it so mission
accomplished there
nice
and um
[Music]
next joke this one was on our Facebook
group
I'm not sure
whose this was
um let me see if I can find their name
because we're reading them from Facebook
and
YouTube
I don't know who this one is oh wait I
think this is Hulen so yes Victoria
asked for reading from Facebook yeah I'm
reading from both I'm just going in
order as they appear
um
so this is Hulen Sanders
Saunders I've been watching is this
yours or mine I don't know no I think
it's true mine yeah I've been watching a
lot of scared straight lately to let my
kids know I have options have you seen
the show they should have named it get
straight or get gapped
because they're
oh I guess he got gapped
he couldn't finish the joke he got
gapped
oh my
so yeah
it's supposed to be gapped because I
don't know what gapped is maybe yeah
maybe he meant the r word I don't know
yeah that's probably it but
I'm watching a lot of scared straight
lately to let my kids know I have
options
have you seen the show it's almost like
it's like two different things going on
here it's like you're doing a silly like
prison
stereotype joke but then you're also
you're setting it up as like this you're
watching Scared Straight to like educate
your family I like that angle of it
better
and I think you kind of like laughed
when you said to show my kids I have
options
yeah that's the I think for me that's
probably that's that's the most personal
part like I've seen Scared Straight I
know what it's about but the fact that
you're letting your kids watch it to
know that you have options that's funny
to me like that's the part
human that's the human element of
watching Scared Straight we all have
seen the show but yeah so I think I'd go
deeper on
having your kids watch the show that's
funny
yeah yeah I agree I think raising your I
think that's the funnier premise than
this late like the the prison sex or
whatnot I mean that's played it's like
what like we said to with like JT's joke
what can you do that's unique to you and
your life
and showing your kids scared straight to
like you know I think that's a hilarious
premise you can really dive into
yeah
yeah that's that's funny like yeah
like they like they steal something and
then they gotta watch like three hours
of scared straight you mean like that'd
just be hilarious
yeah to show I have options I mean yeah
I like I like where it's headed yeah
focus more on that aspect of it like
raising your kids with
um scared straight or like that's like
their cartoons or instead of Dora the
Explorer
it's
um T-Bone from cell nine or something
you know like on the Explorer Paw Patrol
maybe it's just on patrol we don't watch
PAW Patrol we watch on patrol maybe
there could be something there you know
um
but yeah nicely gone there
I just look down there thanks for
sharing fam
yeah
um
next joke
this is Poppy Javi he didn't put joke in
front of it so if y'all do post your
jokes put joke in front of it but I
think this is a joke all right I grew up
going to Catholic church every Sunday
and I hated it it would take forever to
finish and it got worse throughout the
years because the older the priest got
the harder it was to make him come
laughs
oh my heavenly day
I wish I would have saw this before I
read it oh my heavenly day
here's the thing I'm not laughing
because it's funny just so you know
[Laughter]
amen amen take them to church yo she
take them to church I gotta give you
that context I'm laughing because this
is terrible
[Laughter]
oh my gosh yeah that's gross
yeah it's it's kind of like the prison
sex joke it's like it's been done you
know like what how else can you make
like a clever Catholic Church joke you
know beyond like
priest sex you know it's kind of been
done
yeah and I think this is where like you
really have to challenge yourself yeah
that if someone has done these like so
many people have done these jokes so
many times right audiences have already
seen them like and I I think when people
go to watch like stand up
if they've already seen everything that
has been done like on late night TV or
any reference to that you're not going
to stand out you're just like okay this
is just the noise yeah so I was this is
one of those jokes like just you could
do better than this
that's all I'll say like yeah I was
laughing because you know yeah sure it
might like you also have to remember
that this then becomes your persona that
you do these jokes on stage
and you got to think about that like so
first of all if somebody like uh I would
say if somebody who's in this group was
to watch you at an open mic do this joke
there's some people that would never
ever book you for any shows yeah yeah
that's true yeah
it's a little tough love but it's kind
of like you know we wanna
you know part of the mission here is to
help cultivate the next generation of
great comics and part of that is like
hey here's a lot of common mistakes we
see young Comics making
here's the reality of the joke we're
reading but here's how we can improve on
it in terms of like just making it more
personal not just playing on stereotypes
and stuff and things that like you said
have been
that road's been hoed for years
yes
all right
next joke yeah
um
it's Akuma
uh if there are inch worms are there
mile worms somewhere in the world if
there are I hope they don't evolve into
tapeworms
foreign
I like the word play
I like the word play that's a I'm almost
wondering if it's like a bulimia joke
because I think or a tapeworm drip like
there's something about tapeworms
because tapeworms are
like I think there's a scientific
element that would work for this but I
think we don't know hit it's akuma's
like opinion or connection to this it's
kind of like a Mad Lib you know there's
no real joke structure yeah
yeah yeah it sounds funny and it is
funny
but it's not personal at all
and we have no connection to
how you feel about it either you just
kind of
give an observation
yeah take give an inchworm and they take
a mile worm I don't know
yeah this is itsakuma is not in this
joke so it's kind of just like a random
Mad Lib right now
they take a tapeworm yeah oh yeah inch
worm tapeworm yeah measuring tape ooh
measuring tapeworm perhaps with inch in
a mile
maybe something there
um
keep it rolling here because my in-laws
are here and I do
I do um
I can't be in here yelling and into the
internet forever this evening
um I have to act like I'm I have to be
professional and be like oh there's a
good one in there we had a lot of super
chats and um
um here's dad
I think this one's yours oh okay
um when I was a little kid I didn't know
I could have milk so when my Mexican mom
gave me some my stomach would hurt I
tell her I wasn't feeling well and I
think I'm gay
it feels like a mark Normand
it is it like it feels like something
Mark Norman
yeah it's
I mean the I like the ultimate misdirect
but like I think I'm
it's missing something for me and I
think part of it is like it feels too
left field it doesn't feel real yeah he
said it's a three-part joke
oh well
goodness gracious
let's get the first part funny before we
try to work on three Heaven's the Betsy
guys it's three parts you got you gotta
read the whole Soliloquy to really get
the pros of my comedic genius it's like
well let's get 10 words funny before we
write a whole essay here uh but um
right there
funny and then we get another part yeah
yeah
the Joel Osteen joke's been working too
that's been fun to do
I want I want one day it blows up and
then he pays me 50 racks to come perform
in his church that's what I'm 50 racks
is what I'm going for what would he do
it what would he do
we do it
but I say that's I will say
um Mr dad I like how personal this is
you're talking about your childhood you
have a Mexican mom it's about your
relationship that's why I like how
personal it is
um it just yeah the gay thing it yeah it
doesn't um
yeah it wouldn't if it makes your
stomach hurt then there's probably
something around like having to poop or
something like
so the the other context is that when we
ask for uh joke feedback we try to limit
it into just like one joke right into
one space rather than like three parts
and I don't know if you haven't been
here before Dad
um so everything we try to do is just we
try to fit it we always say if it needs
like multiple parts
you're probably not getting to the funny
fast enough if it needs multiple parts
for us to get to the phone yes
good point yeah that is something we say
especially on YouTube well they'll
um yeah they they limit your character
count so we've been doing this long
enough to know if if you can't fit it in
that first box and you have to like make
it a two-parter then
um
yeah then yeah edit it down
oh but Corey's getting antsy Cory's like
well how do we know if we've only heard
one third of it how do we know it's
funny well then
also with the punch line
I wasn't feeling well and I think I'm
gay
I think you're leaving a lot of room for
more jokes after that
so that's why I think like there's more
to this so I think some people
definitely was like okay that's a nice
little misdirect I think for me though
it was just like oh okay I feel like I
wanted more so for me I'm waiting for
more things to be said based on the fact
that you've got a surprising punchline
and I don't I don't even see the rest of
it in the live chat because he's
fighting back Dad's getting he's getting
personal he he you know he's like no
that's not the punch line I can't even
there's there's it's funny it's comedy
gold Fu Joel Michael Sarah you don't
know what comedy is despite being a
professional for over 12 years and
interviewing over 400 comedians you
don't know comedy I know comedy
[Music]
uh
but yeah I honest I honestly don't even
see because I would I would like to give
it a chance but honestly don't even see
the rest of it
um in the live chat so I'm not sure
where
yeah I don't know all I see is that and
then I see he posted a joke about having
an Asian friend
which doesn't seem connected to that
um
yeah so I don't know there buddy
but thank you
for helping
thanks thanks for posting
um
all right let's uh let's let's let's
let's get to let's get to let's get to
these as quick as possible here let's
next one
um
where are the jokes Bobby Sutton
here we go
uh I was an unpopular kid who grew up in
a house with three ghosts one of them
was my age and I'll tell you it really
affects your confidence when even Casper
won't play with you
okay okay
[Music]
yeah I like the premise of it especially
since you set us up with the fact that
you were unpopular kid
yeah I like how personal it is it's
almost like growing up in a haunted
house made me the unpopular kid like
even the ghosts wouldn't play with me or
even the ghosts bullied me it could be
something like that
yeah
because I don't know one of them was my
age it affects your confidence when even
Casper won't play with you
I think it could be like changed to more
like that
yeah I think even if you you may not
even need that middle part I think
um like one of them was my age
I would just say I tell you it really
affects your confidence when even the
Casper won't play with you like just
that I think just
shorten the joke up and then get to that
funny fast that's true yeah because the
age thing you don't really need or
anything like that and you can still get
the joke out
more efficiently
that's funny I like that Bobby yeah
that's fun
believe me oh that's hilarious the ghost
bullying you yeah yeah I would love to
hear more about that though in your
relationship with those ghosts
uh cause that is hilarious premise and
it's true and unique to you Bobby is
always fun
um I think this is uh Victoria in our
Facebook group
oh
whoa
D Mr dad you should have posted our
Facebook group because there are no
character limits over there
holy comedy
I need a bookmark to finish this joke
all right let's see if we can get
through this bad boy
today Jesus was on Tinder how would that
look his profile he has his robe Bond
his hair is long and his beard he looks
a bit like a mess he's wearing his
sandals and his mother is a Jew and
she's like really Jesus did you have to
wear those sandals you're 36 000 years
old you have to get you married his
profile says Carpenter so he's poor he
isn't a contractor and then you find out
he is on j-day and Christian Mingle so
he's a player and on Jay date he has a
12 followers and on Christian Mingle he
has billions of followers so he is a
player then you write to him and he says
do you know who my father is so Jesus
has an attitude plus he is a Capricorn
ladies you would all swipe left for the
Son of God all right
kudos to gnocchi really earning his keep
reading that one
um I like the bit the whole bit is
actually pretty solid yeah I like the
premise
I like the premise because the premise
of Jesus on Tinder and now there's
things within here
his profile picture I don't think like
the the Christian Mingle and Jade ate
like if Jesus was on Tinder it's
basically what would his profile look
like and just getting those details out
as like more efficiently than whatever's
going on here
for sure so oh or I think I actually
think the real premise is that Jesus
being on a dating sites Jesus being on
dating sites and then you go to each one
then you have an example of Jesus on
Tinder oh he's got the long hair but
he's got his friends cut out or
something like that if he was on
Christian Mingle there we go
tons of followers if he was on j-date
he's only have a couple of followers
like then the big premises can you guys
imagine if Jesus was on yeah yeah yeah
there it is yeah yeah that's weird yeah
that's the premise at the top say that
at the top Jesus on dating sites and
then you can go through each one and
have these punch lines yes
good edit there yeah yeah because there
are there are a lot of good uh jokes in
there it's just setting it up to be all
dating and not just Tinder
nice
very nice
um
next up we have Gene
Gene
uh Jackson I'm a pretty negative person
people ask are you glass half empty or
glass half full I tell them neither I'm
more of who cares I'm sure somebody spit
in it type person
foreign
I like the premise and I like the punch
line I just think it's just a little
wordy
um because I think just a punchline of
I tell them neither I'm more of a who
spit in the glass kind of guy you mean
like I think that's more on a
performance side too because you almost
have to sell how apathetic you are to
the glass half full half empty question
and I think and I think it could just
all be personalized too instead of
people ask blank it could be like I'm a
pretty negative person I don't I don't
see a glass half full or half empty or I
see someone spit in it something like
that
yeah
yeah that's it
yep
I'm not a glass half full or half empty
uh yeah the wording needs to be worked
out but it gets to it quicker
yeah I'm not a Glass Castle
I'm more of who the hell spit in this
glass kind of guy oh yeah there we go
yeah yeah yeah nice
I like that
um
[Music]
who is next let's see Untitled show
and let me just text my wife
um
is this is this yours to read
yeah I tried mushrooms for the first
time the other day which was a big deal
for me because I normally just like
pepperoni
silly
that's silly
I enjoyed that I was not expecting that
it's very silly very
yeah you just took a very different left
turn well done especially with Comics
right like I think we're all expecting
something completely different but that
was pretty good
I like the misdirect yeah around the
pizza and mushrooms pepperoni
yeah just know that like you couldn't do
this like in a
because families would really be
thinking it's like mushrooms mushrooms
for real
so just know that like a crowd has to
almost know that you're going that route
oh it's like mushroom drugs but the the
it's actually mushroom pizza yes like
people have to know that
yeah it could be I had a life-changing
experience the other day I just tried
mushrooms which was a big deal because I
normally just like pepperoni
so it builds up that misdirect even more
being like this life changing mushroom
experience yep yeah that's a good edit
that's a good idea so that assumption
even more yes
um
[Music]
let me scroll down really quick to see
if
um if I'm getting roasted I feel kind of
bad I feel like we were a little hard on
Mr dad but I mean he seems to have
forgiven us okay I mean the joke but I
just you know I don't I don't want
anyone to leave here and be like well if
them how dare they do this free live
stream every week just to make us feel
terrible it's like no I just want to
make sure you know now my
my self-consciousness is like but I'm
sorry
um
but uh let me see
um oh I didn't even see Mr dad gave us a
Super Chat
there you go there's the sharehorn
thanks for sharing some love there and
he said he posted the full joke in
Facebook
so um
I'll be sure to check it out uh after
the live stream
um I don't think we'll get to it on the
live stream but I'll be sure to get back
to you there Mr bad oh he said oh no I'm
gonna bury you that's hilarious
we're like that's the facts kids and I
were like I'm sorry
um
let's see
uh nice mushroom pepperoni mistake
though that was really fun
um Harry Pike
yo and I just want to say we've been
like over 30 strong for like most of
this live stream so shout out to
everyone hanging out with us the numbers
keep growing here which is so dope
because I've seen bigger channels than
this have less people on their live
streams so the community here is
incredible
um is this yours or mine I think you
read the last
this is mine I realized I couldn't
become a veterinarian when I became
addicted to a book about dogs
I couldn't put it down
oh man
[Music]
um this is good I think the big key to
this is uh especially for him when
you're performing that pause
I couldn't and then pause put it down
like almost like sell that as much as
possible but that's funny that's really
funny
I agree yeah yeah I like just making
sure that pauses there but otherwise I
think this joke
I saw it didn't become a veterinarian
when I became addicted to a book about
dogs
I just couldn't put it down I don't I
don't really have any notes I mean I
wonder if he's done I wonder if Harry's
done this on stage because I definitely
especially with his delivery because I
know he has a nice like dry delivery
um
I think as long as that pauses there I
think I think the joke's there man
that's fine
unless they're done there
[Applause]
nicely done their hair
um
[Laughter]
next
where are we what is life
um
here we go
in college my GPA was only a 1.5 luckily
resume math means 1.5 rounds up to 2.0
[Laughter]
um
this is funny but I actually think it'd
be better if the stakes were a little
higher
I think I want well maybe just because I
know GPA and a 1.5 is like super low
versus like if you did like a 3.5 and
then you rounded it up to a 4.0
because the 4.0 is like a perfect grade
basically yeah yeah
but I wonder if even for comedic effect
like exaggerate even more wait did you
just say 1.5 to 4.0
yeah so you said okay sorry I thought
you were saying making no you said 3.5
to 4 Points right you know but I think
that's funny though I think your point
of like exaggerated even more yeah
luckily based on the collars that I went
to a 1.5 rounds up to a 19.0 you know
I'm saying or something ridiculous yeah
yeah or even like maybe a 4.0 just
because it's resume math I think it
would get the point across there and
it's exaggerated enough for comedic
effect oh my God can you imagine if
you're like my my GPA was only a 1.5
luckily resume math means I also speak
Spanish you mean or like oh something
completely left turn yeah yeah yeah
that means I'm good at parties or
um
yeah that's true yeah so even something
not relating to GPA could be funny
yeah
yeah I like that
nicely done that though good word
economy though Jerry
good word economy
um
uh add a job reference I think that's
fun
that would be fun like that would be
smart to add like a job reference to it
like I went for a job as a you know
as a professor or something else and
yeah like just adding a job reference
will make it more personalized too
nice
um
Justin Fleming
uh it only takes three babies to make
one bottle of baby oil
less for baby food
um that's dark
um
[Laughter]
it's stupid I know and if this is part
of his like on stage persona
it may it could fit but as we're reading
it there's no context right now it's
kind of like
a statement I need a little more context
to this
you know it and I think
I think the three babies to make it is
the actual punch line so I think maybe
it's like
baby I heard baby oil is bad for the
environment it requires three babies to
make it
or something like that
so now the three babies making it is the
actual punch line because that's really
where the misdirect comes in for sure
yeah
what do you think of that
I like that yeah yeah because you're
right the punchline
shouldn't be in the middle of the
sentence it should be at the end
yes yeah yeah
but I think it could be there especially
if it fits your like persona it's a bit
dark and weird
but it's silly enough to where it could
maybe work now Justin's gonna go do it
and it's gonna bomb and he's gonna be
like
him and Mr dad start like their own
Facebook group anti-hotch breath
Michael Sarah
Michael Sarah quit acting and started
giving job feedback his career is a joke
next to the year on Reddit like what do
you guys think yeah yeah
[Laughter]
um
Mookie
wait
is that the joke I followed my first
trans person on only fans
I don't get it
um if it was if the site was only trans
Maybe
um
but otherwise I don't know I don't know
where Mookie
I followed my first trans person
yeah it still feels like a setup it can
only be on the only chance there's no
way it's gonna just don't only fans
because that's just a mismatch
I deleted that mookie said oh thank
goodness we will delete it as well
[Laughter]
good call
you did it for us there mookie
um
I don't even know where that's one of
those
um
that's one of those that like us
comedians will type on our phone we'll
just be like randomly at like the
grocery store and be like Oh that'll get
them and then we look at it later and
we're like what
what
[Music]
um
I think we just have like
let me scroll let me scroll let me
scroll let me scroll let me scroll let
me scroll
um
I think can we get to Dad's joke
where's Dad's joke
I see Riley's here's one from the
Facebook oh wait no I think that is
that's wholey Julian's
okay
um so let's get to the ones we haven't
read yet Riley
I was a good kid at school
I was known as The Golden Child and at
home I was known as a golden shower
child
Obviously good
I don't know what a golden shower child
is but my only thought is golden shower
is getting peed on right so like it
feels naughty or just dirty just out the
gate
yeah I wonder if um it's something about
him running the bed what do you
sorry I cut you off there
you know I said this has R Kelly Vibes
oh gosh and Riley looks young so it may
it may be onto something here
he looks young in that profile picture
and he's given that face like you wanna
you wanna
give me that yeah yeah
I was a good kid at school I was known
as the golden at home yeah I think if
it's golden shower then that's like a p
reference so it needs to be like that
you wet you used to wet the bed or
something
so like at school my teeth like
yeah we need we need a little more
context because right now at home I was
known as the golden shower child
like why you know I get golden child
you're saying I was a good kid at school
I was known as a golden child that
correlates but then at home golden
shower we need a little more context to
why that was
Riley said R Kelly would love me oh my
heavens
hilarious
yeah just a little more context maybe
because you used to wet the bed or
something we need a little more context
there buddy
um and this may be the last oh Court
wait we already read Corey's didn't we
Corey was like the first one we read
yeah yeah the slip and slides
so I'm seeing
idiot
on the comedy circuit I think that's the
next one I'm seeing
and this might be the last one
um
both my brothers are divorced and my
wife doesn't like me hanging out with
them because they may accidentally show
me what it looks like to be happy
[Music]
[Laughter]
both my brothers are divorced and my
wife doesn't like me hanging out with
them because they may accidentally show
me what it looks like to be happy
I don't hate that
that's pretty funny that's very funny
yeah that's solid
um
uh
yeah I can't think of any other yeah I
can't think of anything for I was trying
to think of a tag or something to it uh
because I like this as it is really
oh yeah and people are saying they like
that one yeah I don't
I don't think there's anything I mean
like
it's
I mean yeah I mean I might like I might
take away the word accidentally
like oh yeah yeah
just
like overall
I yeah yeah I like that accidentally
it's a long kind of like clunky word
that I think taking that out makes the
punch line have a little more umph to it
yeah yeah that's a good edit there
yeah
yeah and then like even like they may
show me what it looks like pause to be
happy
yeah that's what I was trying to think
of where the pause would be it could be
there it could be they'd like me hanging
out with them cuz pause
they'd show me what it looks like to be
happy like you may play around with
where but I think I like it though yeah
I think that's a great one to end on
what do you think there Yoshi
I agree I uh agree
well done everyone
[Applause]
they really have yeah yeah they really
have
So yeah thank you everyone for hanging
out oh my gosh we do this every Tuesday
at 5 PM eastern time so do come back
bring your friends
tell them we ouch yeah
and of course you know we got that
podcast posting every week as well
um
I'll be gone next week
oh Mr dad's still talking about his joke
I really I do want to hear the joke
because I mean we've we've we've gone
this far and he did a super chat so
we might as well
um you can do the honors
all right when I was a little kid I
didn't know I couldn't have milk so when
my Mexican mom gave me some my stomach
would hurt and tell her I wasn't feeling
well and I think I'm gay my mom being
Mexican would freak out and start
praying Santo
after about an hour I take a heat [__]
and I feel better I had some ice cream
earlier today now I feel gay
deals amigo
Que lastima
mi familia
pero estoyaki
leiendo esta chiste
Que elastima
laughs
we tried
I want everyone watching this
I like the short one better yeah
[Laughter]
I will say it was worth it though that
was worth it
that was so worth it I feel like he knew
it
I feel like he's like oh man if they
hate this first part just wait till they
hear the next two parts
[Laughter]
oh that's that's how you end the joke
feedback yeah yeah yeah
hilarious
elements
all right
yeah but I mean I like how it's personal
it's it's personal
I think there's just moments I think
the big thing here is you're not getting
to the
punches soon enough and there's like too
many gaps before you get to like the
next funny part I like so I think this
is one of those things that you just got
to get to the funny earlier
and then sort of give examples because I
think that's what's kind of missing here
is that it takes us a while
to set the table of the scenes
yeah and really this this joke seems to
be more about his relationship and like
within his family and how maybe him and
his mom are always having these
miscommunications or something so it
that's where the joke seems to be more
than just like oh now I feel gay it's
like the whole joke is built around like
I'm gay now here's a call back at the
end I'm gay it's like the humor for me
is in like the relationship with your
mom so write more about that and I think
you'll find a lot there
yeah
great job people are like put it out of
its misery that's hilarious that's what
it's Akuma said he's like yeah
he said it's a lactose intolerant joke
but I
can tolerance
yeah funny and tolerant I think that's
what we're getting at is we're trying to
make it a funny tolerant joke right now
it's it's right now it's it's
intolerable you know
um
but there's no lactose yeah no just
straight up
hilarious
but yeah thank I'm glad we got to that
though so I don't have to go back to it
later I didn't have to roast him in the
Facebook group
uh
hilarious
but nice job everyone oh my gosh that
was fun
that was awesome we did it thank y'all
for hanging out do tell your comedian
friends about us man this YouTube
channel our podcast hot breath the
Facebook group all of it man we out ya
that was fun but now Yoshi's like oh no
I have to go back to family he's like oh
no my children they can no longer rate
he should go upstairs it's gonna like
Lord of the Flies it's just they're just
gonna
that's typically what happens
like when I disappear like I just grow
up it's just like this mess like my kids
I I do write about this in a bit it's
like I've watched him
and they're okay walking around the
house and just like
as if though it's like uh
floors on block the floor is lava
they'll just walk around stuff that's
their [__] like and just be like
completely okay with that I'm just like
did you not see like your shirt on the
ground oh that's mine that's weird
I'll go pick it oh my it's ridiculous my
my wife calls it her trail of
Destruction
yes she does that too
yeah
yeah especially like sometimes in the
bathroom when like my littlest one it
would just take off all his clothes just
to go in the bathroom and then it just
looks like a ghost just was just in
there just like what
it's hilarious
the layers of clothes a shirt pants
underwear just like he like managed
that's so funny
that's hilarious
oh well thank you Christopher said you
guys rule thank you so much we
appreciate that y'all rule as well for
hanging out with us we really do
appreciate it
we do this every Tuesday we do a live
stream every Wednesday our right tank
club we do a daily joke running contest
in our Facebook group go listen to this
week's podcast we do a monthly joke
writing contest where the winner gets
100 bucks an interview on the podcast so
that's worth listening to this week's
episode
but um
I think I think we've done it
did it we did it baby let's
um let's land This Plane yes we would
love to perform in the UK for sure
and Mr Dad this is how we get better so
no worries there are no no worries my
friend this is how we get better
what's up Ruda speaks what's goody fam
we outcha
and as Bobby said Angel's on y'all let's
angels on y'all
let's land This Plane get forth with our
days
angels on y'all we love you all though
thank you for hanging out
see you next week bye